[Musique]
comment cette édition d'antenne de midi
avec deux invités jacqueline julien et
lino ventura parce que ils ont tous les
deux un point commun ils s'occupent des
enfants en france et dans le monde
jacqueline julien amnesty international
s'occupe de l'enfance torturé un rapport
vient d'être publié nous en parlerons
dans un instant innovant tuera à vous
c'est dans la banlieue parisienne que
vous avez découvert ces jours derniers
certains diront la méchanceté et la
majorité d'iran l'égoïsme et une partie
de la population de sèvres s'oppose en
effet à la construction d'un centre pour
handicapés aux handicapés mentaux un
centre dans la construction était
envisagée par l'association pour vous
occuper
écoutez je voulais pas que cette affaire
soit ébruitée avant la réunion du
conseil municipal de servir le 26
octobre mais comme vous savez et les
choses la rumeur publique pas très vite
alors endemol a de quoi il s'agit j'ai
effectivement acheté un terrain à sèvres
qui font mener parfaitement
l'implantation d'un centre pour ses
enfants
c'est comprenant une
un chant et des ateliers où ils pourront
traiter dans un foyer à vie bien sûr
tout ça encadrés par des éducateurs
comme il se voit or moi ce n'est pas le
premier foyer que vous n'avez en france
justement la première fois que vous avez
des problèmes - j'ai déjà eu des
problèmes sont là n'ont pas pas à pas à
ce niveau alors bien entendu je suis ici
pour dire sur tout à fait des choses
avant de faire le moindre eux jettent
dans ce centre je suis allé voir la
mairie de serres et le maire notamment
qui bien sûr a accueilli favorablement
au projet c'est la moindre des choses
or dans ce domaine ya une chose qui est
encore beaucoup plus apprécié qu'on a
même utilisé la diffamation et on a
accusé le maire de sf de toucher des
pots-de-vin de matha post à construire
une somptueuse villa oui on en a eues
avec des enfants c'est un dramatique
je me demande qu'est ce qui va se passer
le maxi quelqu'un a besoin d'un secours
d'un verre d'eau dans la rue je ne sais
plus bien donc vous n'avez pas envisager
bien sûr une seconde de renoncer à ce
centre pas encore pendant qu hors jeu
les commentaires sont ils ont partagé là
bas certains disent et parce que c'est
une histoire de gros sous ou venez nous
le rappeler d'autres shows disent ça va
faire perdre de la valeur à
l'envahissement vraiment une grosse ou
qu'est ce que ça veut dire j'ai acheté
un terrain tôt m 25 ans pas trés trés il
faut se faire pardonner de faire du bien
c'est un qui vous fait alors je
comprends plus rien voilà que tout à été
puis je laisserais tomber sous les
halles et sur la taille des décennies de
rencontrer le nom vaut mieux va t il
tomber parce qu'on a employé la du monde
monsieur qui sont vraiment impossible à
dire ici je n'ose même pas les dire
pourquoi je crois que c'est un sujet que
l'on peut effectivement mettre sur la
place publique avec un volet largement
utilisé contre vous en jeu égal contre
l'association vous dire quelque chose
s'ils ont quelques soignants vont venir
me dire personnellement et je les
attends seulement j'en ai pas encore vu
un jour eh bien au roi également un
problème de la rumeur publique
oui et non mais moi je vois bien au roi
il veut lui quand ça fait un bon moment
croyez moi
non c'est pas ta me suivez vous conduit
dans cette campagne il ya une quinzaine
d'années la plus belle lettre que j'ai
reçue après cette campagne cela l'aide
d'une mère de famille qui m'a écrit m'a
dit monsieur ventura je vous remercie
parce que maintenant grâce à vous je
peux aller faire mes courses avec
matthew enjeux guarente on est content
on en était à 15 ans on les cachait les
ont pas profondément mon amour pour mes
cages
ça n'a pas du tout changé pour l'envoyer
voilà qui m'avaient appelée pour me
réussit aujourd'hui c'est pour moi qui
ai demandé à venir mais la rumeur avait
appelé il ya nous avons demandé de venir
[Musique]